>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: IT'S BEEN NEARLY 18
MONTHS.
WE HAVE BEEN KEEPING TRACK AND
HILLARY CLINTON'S BLAME TRAIN IS
NOT CLOSE TO RUNNING OUT OF
RULE.
IT'S CONCERNING.
SPEAKING ON TUESDAY NIGHT AT A
WOMEN'S ONLY CLUB IN NEW YORK,
CLINTON BLAMED EVERYBODY TO THE
NRA TO MISOGYNY FOR HER DEFEAT
IN THE 2016 ELECTION.
HERE'S PART OF IT.
>> I WAS AHEAD.
I GOT MORE VOTES THAN ANYBODY IN
HISTORY EXCEPT ONE TERM OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
EVERY DAY THAT GOES BY, MORE
EVIDENCE, MORE PROOF ABOUT FAKE
NEWS AND THE RUSSIANS AND
CAMBRIDGE ANALYTICA AND SEXISM.
I HAVE TAKEN ON THE NRA FOR
YEARS.
THEY SPENT MORE MONEY AGAINST ME
THAN ANYBODY AND WE KNOW THE
RUSSIAN PAID FOR SOME OF IT.
PAID FOR ACTORS OR RUSSIAN
PERSONNEL TO DRESS UP IN THE
JAIL OUT FITS AND GO AROUND IN A
MOCK JAIL SO PEOPLE COULD YELL
LOCK HER UP.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS MORE LIKE
GROUP THERAPY.
THE EASY THING WOULD BE TO MAKE
FUN EVER HILLARY CLINTON.
BUT IT'S PAST.
THAT.
THIS IS SAD.
WILL ANYONE HELP HER?
IT'S LIKE WATCHING SOMEONE YOU
KNOW FALL APART.
SOMEONE OUGHT TO HELP.
TAMMY BRUCE IS A RADIO HOST.
I AM ONLY HALF JOKING.
THIS IS NOT EMPOWERING FOR
WOMEN.
AS THE FATHER OF THREE DAUGHTERS
I CAN SAY THAT.
>> RIGHT.
THERE IS A POINT WHERE YOU BEGIN
TO FEEL SORRY FOR HER.
AS A POLITICAL PERSON, PART OF
HER COMPLAINT IS THAT FOX NEWS
IS TRYING TO IMPEACH HER.
THERE IS COVERAGE OF HER ON THIS
NETWORK.
THERE IS THE COMPLAINTS HAVE
COME FROM OTHER DEMOCRATS ACROSS
THE NETWORKS.
PEOPLE WHO WORKED FOR HER
CAMPAIGN.
SHE IS IN A UNIQUE POSITION.
SHE IS GETTING COVERAGE AND
CLEARLY SEARCHING FOR RELEVANCE.
SHE COULD TALK ABOUT POLICY AND
USE THIS TO DISCUSS AN ARGUMENT
THAT SHE COULD HAVE --
>> Tucker: THAT'S A SMART POINT.
>> AND MAYBE SHE WOULD BE ON THE
TUCKER CARLSON SHOW.
>> Tucker: SHE IS NOT STUPID.
>> EXACTLY.
>> Tucker: HER CLAIM TO FAME IS
I HAVE READ THE POLICIES.
THERE IS SOME TRUTH IN THAT.
SHE COULD BE DOING THAT BUT
SHE'S NOT.
>> SHE'S BEEN IN THE WHITE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE AND BEEN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE.
YET THIS IS A GROUP THERAPY
DYNAMIC GOING OVER THE SAME
COMPLAINTS, MAYBE PEOPLE THERE
READ HER BOOK.
BUT SHE'S INSERTING NEWS OF THE
DAY.
LIKE SUDDENLY THE CAMBRIDGE
ANALYTICA AND THE NRA.
THAT'S THE NEWS HAPPENING NOW.
AT THIS POINT, IT'S ALMOST AS
THOUGH SHE IS ON AN EPISODE OF
INTERVENTION.
PEOPLE SHOULD TRY TO GET HER
INTO THE VAN TO GET HER TO THE
PLANE TO GET HER TO THE PLACE TO
FIND SOME PEACE.
IT GETS TO A POINT WHERE IT'S
ALMOST AN ABDICATION OF A
RESPONSIBILITY SHE HAS TO HER
FANS AND SUPPORTERS TO DEAL
SERIOUSLY WITH THE ISSUES.
THEY WANT SOLUTIONS.
SHE STILL WITH THIS GREAT
ATTENTION INTERNATIONALLY IS NOT
USING THE PLATFORM SHE HAS TO
PRESENT THOSE SOLUTIONS.
IT'S SAD.
I THINK THERE COULD BE MOVEMENT
FORWARD ON THESE ISSUES.
>> Tucker: THAT'S RIGHT.
WE COULD ADD TO THE SUM TOTAL.
THAT WAS HER SPEAKING LIVE.
WE DON'T HAVE A HUGE DESIRE TO
COVER EVERYTHING HILLARY
CLINTON, DESPITE HER CLAIM.
ONE OTHER POINT.
THE IRONY WHICH PEOPLE ARE NOT
PERCEIVING IS THAT HER PARTY
MOVED FAR FROM WHERE SHE WAS.
SHE IS WAY TOO MODERATE FOR
DEMOCRATS.
>> THAT'S AN INTERESTING
POSITION.
IN ARGUING THE THINGS SHE AND
HER HUSBAND USED TO REPRESENT.
BALANCED BUDGET AND GETTING
PEOPLE OFF WELFARE AND INTO
WORK.
IF SHE WANTED TO BE SERIOUS, SHE
COULD ARGUE ABOUT IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF WOMEN'S LIVES.
SHE SAID NOBODY ELSE HAS BEEN
ATTACKED LIKE HER AND TOLD TO GO
AWAY, BUT GORE AND MCCAIN AND
JOHN KERRY CONTINUED TO TALK
ABOUT POLICY.
WE CAN DISAGREE WITH WHAT THEY
STOOD FOR.
AS A WOMAN THERE ARE SO MANY
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES WITH THE
PLATFORM SHE HAS AND HER OWN
PARTY IS SAYING ENOUGH IS ENOUGH
AT THIS POINT.
>> Tucker: YES.
IF ONE OF MY KIDS ACTED LIKE